for most of us guys has been in this
foreseeing for such a long time we
started off with nothing and we're just
here because we have been fighting for
it
i'm just very lucky to be able to do
something that i love to do i gave
everything to actually become a
professional gamer
esports has had a meteoric rise in the
mainstream accounting for over two
percent of all internet traffic
get right has used that popularity to
turn it into a career
my name is christopher ellison i'm going
by the alias get right
i'm 26 years old from sweden and i play
for my team in india in pajamas
i'm playing a game that's called
counter-strike global offensive
council global offensive is a team-based
game it's five five games it's basically
two 16 rounds and if you come to 16
rounds you win the game it's around 10
years professional i've been playing
this game i never thought it would be my
profession to be a counter-strike player
but it is get right has taken his hobby
all the way to the top taking in over
350 thousand dollars in career earnings
and playing in counter-strike
tournaments all over the world where
millions of people tune in to watch him
and his team ninjas in pajamas
being a professional gamer is
hard
exciting
you're not there just because you're
good at something you're there because
you're doing something that you love to
do
it is very powerful to see how the setup
is for every tournament just look on the
stages that we're playing and we fill up
stadiums everywhere in the around the
world
it's kind of cool to see it how like
people recognize you when you go out to
just buy a coffee at 7 11 or even go on
a cinema or just eating a dinner or
anything like that people will always
recognize you
when you go into different tournaments
like here in eleague or esl it's very
very needed they have the top-notch
computer the top-notch monitor the
top-notch stage everything has to be
perfect
i still feel enjoyed to play games
feeling that moment when you just want a
torment and you're feeling like those
emotions that comes with it i think
that's motivates me to keep on going
just years after years of the years i'm
not doing just because it's my work i do
it because
i love it
you